anybody who would violate your
Constitution potentially use physical
violence to end democracy is a is a
tyrant is a dictator Tucker Carlson is
in Spain right now out there protesting
with the people trying to save their
country check this out anybody who would
violate your Constitution potentially
use physical violence to end democracy
is a is a tyrant is a dictator and this
is happening in the middle of Europe so
we thought it deserved more coverage
than it's
getting
if your government is allowing
foreigners to come in and hurt you
they're committing war against you you
know our news media doesn't report a lot
of things and in our time here it's very
obvious that the Socialists in an
alliance with a separatist are trying to
end the rule of law in Spain if you
don't have freedom of speech you don't
have the freedom to defend yourself and
you can't vote your way out of it the
system is rigged you're in real trouble
real trouble so I I'm really rooting for
your success is the world actually
seeing how um important is what is
happening here no no the world is not
seeing how important it is um but we
hope to change that yeah I'm sure you
will thank you very much we hope to
change that indeed and Tucker Carlson is
doing the right thing again I I'm not an
expert in every little bit of what is
happening on the ground there uh but
does the idea of the elites flooding
your country with people who shouldn't
be there and growing signs of socialism
and stamping down on descent and all of
that kind of stuff that sound like maybe
kind of a little bit of what's going on
here too so you might want to care
what's happening in Spain right that's
why these things you don't have to care
about the Jews particularly but you
might want to care about what's
happening to Israel a western democracy
in a place where there isn't a lot of
that you may not care about the Spanish
people specifically or you might not
care about Western Europe but you might
go oh there's something happening there
that could kind of happen here and of
course because of the internet and
because of phones our connectivity and
the ability for these riots whether
they're riots to tear down Societies or
whether they're protests to uphold the
goodness of society they can spread like
wildfire so this is what's happening in
America right now we have a political
party and and by the way the Republicans
kind of suck too right but we have a
political party of the Democrats that
are trying to flood America with
non-westerners who will vote for
Democrats and then eventually they will
have the house they will have the Senate
they will have the White House and what
will they do but you know what it's not
just them because yes I often say I am a
Florida Republican very proudly first
time I ever registered as a republican
here in Florida but the national
Republican project I don't know what to
make of it I really do not know what to
make of
it